we had ourselves a nice little run going
there didn't we
you're up early just shaking off the
cobwebs before school starts you know I
find it hard to believe you have any
cobwebs up there here why not let me
help you I can't have our famous author
hurting her hands very funny
seriously though I'm I'm happy to
publisher realized how special you are
hmm he's not the only one
Thank You Elizabeth um I was wondering
if you if you weren't what I was gonna
say is if you were not yes maybe another
time
[Music]
come in wow this place is spotless
well Lee's sister is coming oh that's
fantastic
she changed her mind yes but you know
there are some culture dynamics going on
between the two of them that I won't
pretend to understand Oh all right so
tell me tell you why I can read you like
a book you are bursting at the seams
with some news so spill it speaking of
books you know that publisher who read
my work yes well he is paying me in
advance to publish my novel
really so I suppose Lucas is forgiven
seems I can't stay angry with him for
too long you do do have an awful lot in
common rosemary don't start although you
and Nathan seemed to have patched things
up as well hmm
what am I gonna do what are you going to
do I don't know
well sooner or later you're going to
have to decide I know I think by not
deciding in a way I'm protecting myself
from letting in either of them we all
have our own path when the time is right
for you to choose you'll know
[Music]